so I'm telling you right straight out
that if you are at all sensitive if
you're at all queasy then don't watch
this film just put on the the late night
movie I feel it's important that people
know the truth very happy John Kennedy
was our president he died for what he
believed him and I felt that we had no
right to turn our back on his memory
please narrate what we're saying as
getting a copy of the famous home movie
of the Kennedy assassination would
change Robert Roy white shooter was a
Dallas dress manufacturer when he
revealed these a pruder film on good
night America and led to a job as the
chief photo optics consultant for the
House Select Committee on assassinations
created in part as a response to the
release of the film they in their final
report said that it was in fact
organized crime that there was in fact a
conspiracy when the sixth floor museum
opened in Dealey Plaza
Robert was surprised they wouldn't talk
about any of the other theories they
just didn't want the truth out there and
that upset me it upset me terribly so I
moved down here and started set up in
Dealey Plaza on weekends to let people
know that there was an alternative to
the official fiction and the city didn't
like that sixth floor museum didn't like
that over the course of 25 years in
Dealey Plaza Robert has been arrested
twice and has been ticketed by the city
82 times I've won every case all of
those cases because I hadn't broken any
laws the stuff that they charged me with
for incredible things
vending on private property selling
private property many on public
properties only personal property
blocking sidewalks even though we
weren't on the sidewalk vending without
a permit
no permits don't exist they just don't
exist there aren't any there's no need
for them you couldn't buy one if you had
a billion dollars you know that's the
whole idea of arresting somebody in the
United States of America for selling a
magazine that's what he was arrested for
selling a magazine one time the city
said did Homeland Security complete with
the outfits and machine guns a little
bit it really got ridiculous I mean I'm
not a danger to anybody the original
charges were based on one orders to
identify and when that was pointed out
to the municipal courts they amended the
the charges against him to sign of
different ordinance which also did apply
they just didn't want me there they
wanted me gone and they felt that
arresting me would would scare me off
for 20 years Robert has been placing the
iconic X on the exact spot where Kennedy
was shot the city came by and they dug
up that entire section of Street to get
rid of the X can you believe it when we
asked why he said we know anyone
tripping over the X like maybe a quarter
of a millimeter thick it's crazy all
this for just speaking my mind I'm an
actually important issue after the
second arrest in 2010 Grodin took the
case to trial and as always the charges
were dismissed this time however the
city appealed the dismissal of a Class C
misdemeanor is not appealed it's never
appealed that I talking to criminal
defense lawyers around town and even to
the City Attorney's who were involved in
this case Attica they couldn't identify
and no one has been able to buy a single
other case effort in history where the
city of Dallas appealed of dismissal of
a Class C misdemeanor because I began
searching for answers as to why the city
would pursue such a prosecution and in
the process uncovered emails between the
City Council and the sixth floor Museum
they contained detailed discussions
about how to deal with the vendor
problem in Dealey Plaza
according to keziah they were evidence
of intent to maliciously prosecute
Grodin the sixth floor museum in the
city of Dallas
to comment on the story he would have
been arrested at the 6th floor Hanna
called that day the day that he was
arrested that's that's for sure a friend
of mine bailed me out within an hour and
a half of the arrest
they held me for an additional nine
hours the city attorney could have shut
that down obviously could have and
should have after the appeal and once
again dismissal of the case Rodan and
keziah
took both the sixth floor museum and the
city of dallas to court on the grounds
that they conspired to violate Grodin's
First Amendment rights the sixth floor
museum wants to be the only game in town
there's no question about that they
don't like what I've got to say they're
like what any of anybody in Dealey Plaza
has to say as a matter of fact it was it
was a judge city judge who had
originally suggested that we file a
federal suit because was a federal case
and he was getting tired of seeing my
face they're the ones who had him I
called the police to have him arrested
in 2000 2010 even though they knew that
there was no legal basis for his rest
we've said many times through the years
this is Dallas leave your First
Amendment rights at the door in early
2017 a settlement was reached with both
the sixth floor museum and the city of
Dallas for a total of 47 thousand five
hundred dollars according to Robert it
was barely enough to cover the legal
fees he cited the his ailing health and
desire to end the litigation as the
reason for accepting the settlement but
I'm not leaving you advised I'm not
going
anywhere it's been expensive it's been
time-consuming it's been frustrating
it's been anxiety setting but I promise
President Kennedy at his graveside this
silent little thing might sound silly
but I felt it was important that would
be everything within my power as long as
it took to try to find the truth in this
case no matter where it went
and so far I've been able to keep my
word
[Music]
[Music]